loading a custom data set
although the hugging face hub hosts over
a thousand public data sets you'll often
need to work with data that are stored
in your laptop or on some remote server
in this video we'll explore how the data
sets library can be used to load data
sets that aren't available on the huge
face hub
as you can see in this table the data
sets library provides several inbuilt
scripts to load data sets in several
formats
to load a dataset in one of these
formats you just need to provide the
name of the format to the load dataset
function along with the data files
argument that points to one or more file
paths or urls
to see this in action let's start by
loading a csv file
in this example we first download a data
set about wine quality from the uci
machine learning repository
since this is a csv file we then specify
the csv loading script
now this script needs to know where our
data is located so we provide the file
name as part of the data file's argument
and the loading script also allows you
to pass several keyword arguments so
here we've also specified that the
separator is a semicolon
and with that we can see the data set is
loaded automatically as a data set dict
object with each column in the csv file
represented as a feature
if your data set is located on some
remote server like github or some other
repository the process is actually very
similar the only difference is that now
the data file's argument points to a url
instead of a local file path
let's now take a look at loading raw
text files
this format is quite common in nlp and
you'll typically find books and plays
are just a single file with raw text
inside
in this example we have a text file of
shakespeare plays that's stored on a
github repository
and as we did for the csv files we
simply choose the text loading script
and point the data files argument to the
url
as you can see these files are processed
line by line so empty lines in the raw
text are also represented as a row in
the data set
for json files there are two main
formats to know about
the first one is called json lines where
every row in the file is a separate json
object
for these files you can load the data
set by selecting the json loading script
and pointing the data file's argument to
the file or url
in this example we've loaded a json
lines file based on stack exchange
questions and answers
the other format is nested json files
these files basically look like one huge
dictionary so the load dataset function
allows you to specify which specific key
to load
for example the squad data set for
question answering has this format and
we can load it by specifying that we're
interested in the data field
there is just one last thing to mention
about all of these loading scripts
if you have more than one split you can
load them by treating data files as a
dictionary that maps each split name to
its corresponding file
everything else stays completely
unchanged and you can see an example of
loading both the training and validation
splits from squad here
and with that you can now load data sets
from your laptop the hugging face hub or
anywhere else you want